in this episode of myato UI tutorial
series we're creating a basic splash
screen manager that will detect multiple
Splash screens and automatically fade
through each one before loading our
Target scene these tutorials are part of
a long series of user interface
tutorials for gato and as always you can
grab the source files for this and all
of my G tutorials on my patreon first
I've renamed our control nodes and our
splash screen manager scene our Center
container node will act as a splash
screen container and will hold our
multiple Splash screens textur nodes in
our script add a new export variable so
we can reference our splash screen
container node and an array variable to
hold our Splash screens add a new
function get screens that will get the
children of the container and therefore
the texture rect nodes we added then
Loop through each screen and set their
modulate Alpha to zero so they're
transparent the get screens function
gets added to the ready function before
the fade function in the fade function
run a loop through the splash screens
array and for each screen we create the
same tween from the last episode once
the tween is finished it Loops to the
next screen when all screens are
finished we change to our new scene
finally we need a way for the player to
skip the splash screens because everyone
dislikes not being able to skip them add
this function unhandled input to capture
any input event we check if an event is
pressed and if true we load our new
scene you should now be able to add any
number of textur nodes as Splash screens
and have them fade automatically
[Music]